[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS CROSBIE: I'm Chris.
And I'm a product manager here
on our Cloud Dataproc team.
And I'm really excited
for this presentation
because we get to talk
about all the cool features
that we've come up with
since our last Cloud Next.
And I even get to do it with
two of our rock star engineers.
I've got with me Mikayla
as well as Karthik,
and they've actually built
a lot of the features
we're about to show you.
The way I want to start
is just by making sure
that everyone knows everything
that you're about to see
is publicly available.
Go out, kick the tires on it.
We'd love to hear feedback.
You can go use everything we're
about to go to talk about.
Now, I have a ton of
things I want to get to,
so I'm going to just
start to jump in.
And quickly though, before
I do the new features,
I want to quickly baseline
on what Cloud Dataproc is.
So Cloud Dataproc, this
is Google Cloud Platform's
fully managed Apache Spark
and Apache Hadoop service.
And I'm saying Hadoop and
Spark, but it's really
an engine for running lots
of open-source software
in that ecosystem.
We give you customizable
machine types,
meaning that you can have
a set of machine learning
jobs running on one cluster
that might be very compute
intensive, while
at the same time,
you have some ad hoc BI
applications that are running
on a memory-intensive cluster.
And the two never have
to contend for resources
but can still be reading and
writing from the same cloud
storage data sets.
And we also had
some customers that
create very large
customers with us
when they need
clusters like this.
And they can just take them
down when they're done.
So for instance, our engineers
were working with Twitter,
and they received the
note that was like, hey,
are we your largest
Dataproc cluster?
And we kind of
look at each other,
we're like, I don't know,
what are you talking about?
And we went and checked.
And they had actually
needed a 90,000 core cluster
and were able to go,
create that on demand,
never getting a hold
of the Dataproc team,
worrying about procurement.
Just went, created a
90,000-core Dataproc cluster,
and then tore it down when
they were done with it.
And so they were able to do this
because we have a lot of tools
and features that are
specifically designed
for supporting these
kind of architectures
and ephemeral Hadoop and
Spark clusters in general.
And we give you a lot of
tight integration back
to the rest of Google Cloud.
So we are not just giving you
yet another cluster that you're
going to have to go manage.
We are letting you run
all of your existing
open-source software but
still modernizing your stack
as we do this.
And we give our Cloud Dataproc
customers a lot of flexibility
in how they choose to
run the Dataproc service.
So we exposed a lot of knobs.
Now, we try to put sane
defaults on those knobs.
If you don't want
to deal with that,
you can just go and get
started very easily.
But those knobs are
exposed, and so we
have customers that use
Dataproc in a couple
of different models.
The first model is this idea
of a job-scoped cluster.
And this is really effective
for our Cloud Dataproc customers
with batch or ETL-type jobs.
Now in this mode, you
can have a single command
that will send a graph of
jobs to Cloud Dataproc.
We will spin up a right-sized
cluster, run those jobs,
make sure that cluster
gets torn down,
and then save all
of that information
about what happened, all
the logging and audits,
into Stackdriver for you.
And this works really
well with Cloud Dataproc
because we can usually give you
a fully-loaded Hadoop and Spark
cluster in around 90 seconds.
So when you only have a
minute and a half overhead
to create in a
cluster, you can start
to think about jobs and clusters
almost as a single entity.
And we have a lot
of features that
are going to help you with this
model-- things like our jobs
API, workflow templates, and
cluster scheduled deletion.
But we also have
customers that tell us
they have scenarios for
long-running Cloud Dataproc
clusters.
And these might be
scenarios for things like,
if there's a shared interactive
analysis with Jupyter
or Zeppelin notebooks,
or maybe they're
building BI applications
based on Druid.
And we have plenty of features,
like our high availability mode
and our auto-scaler, that are
going to help with this model
too.
And if you want to learn
more, Mikayla and I actually
did a top 10 tips article on
the Google Data Analytics Blog
a couple months
back you can find.
And she even has a webinar
associated with that,
so there's a lot of
materials out there
if you want to know more about
how to run longstanding Cloud
Dataproc clusters.
But regardless of the
model that you choose,
our goal with Cloud Dataproc is
changing open-source software
to be cloud-native.
This means making features there
are going to be fast, easy,
and cost effective.
Last year alone, we put
more than 30 new features
into Cloud Dataproc, and
so this is still an area
Google is heavily investing in.
And so now let's
jump in and actually
start talking about some
of these new features
and what's going on
in Cloud Dataproc.
So I'm going to start
by talking about some
of the recent
open-sourced software
we've recently integrated
with Cloud Dataproc.
Now the theme to
all these features
that I'm about to talk
about is that Cloud Dataproc
lets you take the open-source
tools, algorithms,
and programming languages that
you're already using today
but make it really easy to apply
them to cloud-scaled data sets
while at the same time
helping you integrate
with the entire GCP ecosystem.
We've just recently launched a
new version of Cloud Dataproc.
It's now generally
available, version 1.4.
The headliner on this
version is probably
Spark 2.4, and that comes with
a lot of usability and stability
updates, and that's something
that you can really start
to combine with Cloud Dataproc.
We also had a lot
of customers that
told us, hey, we
love Cloud Dataproc,
but we've built so
much of our enterprise
tooling and internal
standards around Ubuntu.
So we went back and we
recreated Dataproc on Ubuntu,
and that exposed a new
knob, a choice of image
or operating system
type for Dataproc.
Now, for years,
we've had customers
that have built very tight
and sophisticated security
controls with Cloud IAM, and
VM, and cluster isolation.
But we've also
had customers that
wanted the open-source tools,
like Kerberos, built directly
into Dataproc,
which is why we now
have a beta version of Kerberos
integrated with Dataproc.
And this is going to let
you do things like tie back
your Dataproc users
to Active Directory,
or it makes it a
simple button click
to turn on Hadoop secure mode,
or add encryption in-flight.
Tomorrow at 9:00 AM, I'm going
to be speaking with Cloudera
on securing your data lakes.
And essentially, we're going to
have a 55-minute presentation
on this entire slide.
So if you are
interested in what's
going on in Hadoop security,
I would recommend that session
tomorrow morning.
But back to Dataproc
itself, when
you create a
Dataproc cluster, you
can specify what we call
an initialization action.
That's an executable or
script that Cloud Dataproc's
going to run on all
nodes of your cluster
immediately after
that cluster spins up.
Now, we talked to a lot of our
customers and we asked them--
we tried to identify the most
common open-source software
that's being installed
on Cloud Dataproc.
And then what we
want to do is we
try to provide starter
scripts, so everyone's not
rewriting that same code, and
those are the initialization
actions that we put into
our GitHub repository.
Some of the more recent
initialization actions
include Apache Ranger.
And we find a lot
of customers, when
they start with
Cloud Dataproc, they
might be starting with a pretty
monolithic on-prem cluster
that's sharing resources
between ad hoc BI analysts, who
are trying to run
their SQL queries
and waiting for those
queries to come back,
along with a lot of
scheduled and batch jobs that
have piled up over the
last couple of years.
And so one of the first
ways that customers
start to migrate to
the cloud is they
take a lot of those
batch and scheduled jobs
and start putting them
into Cloud Dataproc
to free up that on-prem
cluster for the analyst.
And we've had
customers that said,
hey, the code, it maps over
great, everything runs,
but I would really love to keep
all of my existing security
controls and policies without
redeveloping all of that.
And so that's where something
like the Apache Ranger
initialization action
can really help
get them started doing that.
We've also recently created
an initialization action
for HBase.
And while we do,
at Google Cloud,
have Bigtable, which is a
NoSQL store with HBase API
compatibility, customers,
they've told us,
hey, sometimes I just
need code processors,
or I want to run Apache
Phoenix with SQL,
and so that's why we came
out with Apache HBase.
We also have the
fish that you see
there, that stands for
TonY, or TensorFlow on YARN.
And that's a project
that we did with LinkedIn
that makes it easy
to run TensorFlow
jobs on your Dataproc cluster
without having to move over
to a separate API, like CMLE.
You can just call it directly
from your Spark workflows
and have TensorFlow scale.
And there's actually a full
Next session tomorrow at 11:40
that you might want to
check out if you want
to learn more about that one.
But, again, the theme here--
you're probably sitting here
staring at all of
these open-source logos
and you might be thinking,
hey, doesn't Google
have a fully-managed offering
for some of this stuff?
And you're right.
Oftentimes they do.
But Cloud Dataproc,
our goal is just
to make it easy to run
that open-source version
of the software if
that's your preference.
Now we've also recently had some
optional components that got
promoted to either GA or beta.
And an optional
component, that's
what happens when
initialization actions,
it reaches enough
popularity that we
decide we're going to make this
a first-class Dataproc citizen.
And optional component,
that's software
that you can just add
with a simple checkbox,
and that becomes part
of the Dataproc image.
And so that gives you the
fast clusters spin-up time,
but it also gets
you fully integrated
with all of Dataproc.
And if you want to
know what I mean
by fully integrated,
that's something,
go talk to your
cluster admin about.
They probably know
what it's like to try
to keep up with all
the latest versions
of these various
open-source software
and keep everything in sync.
You install the latest
version of Spark,
a butterfly flaps its wings, it
steps on some Java dependency
over in Zeppelin, and
now all of a sudden all
your class paths are misaligned.
That's the kind of
things that, because we
bake the optional components
into the image itself,
that ensures that
this whole menagerie
of open-source software is
actually working in tandem.
And a new optional component
we just put into alpha
is Druid, a
column-oriented open-source
distributed data store.
You'll most often find
this with OLAP applications
on really high volume data.
So one common use-case that I
keep seeing with GCP customers
is they're taking
something like an Apache
Kafka or a Confluent
incoming stream,
they land all of that data into
a Google Cloud Storage sync,
and then folks want
to see dashboards
on that data about what's
coming in in real time.
And they might want that daily,
they might want that hourly.
And so they can schedule
a Cloud Dataproc cluster
to spin up, run
those aggregations,
upsert that into a long-running
Cloud Dataproc cluster running
Druid, and then tear
down that cluster that
was running those jobs.
And then you have
your application
for the dashboarding
or whatever,
going against that OLAP Cloud
Dataproc store running Druid.
The Dataproc Jobs API,
we have a new SparkR Job
type available for that--
now the Dataproc Jobs API.
That's what makes it
possible to submit
a job to an existing
Cloud Dataproc
cluster with jobs.submit
call over HTTP.
Or if you're on a
command line interface,
you can use GCloud, or even
in the Google Cloud Platform
console itself.
So now it's possible to
submit your SparkR Jobs
through that Jobs API, which
has them logged and monitored,
and that makes it really
easy to build automated
tooling around your R code.
It also makes it
pretty easy to start
separating the
permissions of who
has access to the cluster versus
who has access just to submit
jobs against the cluster.
And you can do that now without
setting up gateway nodes
or something like Livy.
You can just use the Jobs API.
And a new feature that just came
out is this Component Gateway.
And you see what it does here
is, I can now, with one button
click, enable the Component
Gateway, come into the web
interfaces, and it
will expose the web
UIs associated with
the component that
are running on the cluster.
And I can click into those based
on my cloud IAM permissions.
And again, this is a new
feature along the same lines
of the Jobs API,
where we want to make
it easy to access
Dataproc without a bunch
of sophisticated edge
nodes or networking setup.
We want to make it
easy that you can
use GCP as your
security perimeter
for some of the more
common scenarios.
So Component Gateway, it was
built on top of Apache Knox.
And it reverse-proxies
and exposes the web UIs.
And then as long as you have the
proper cloud IAM permissions,
you can directly access them.
So a lot of clouds, when
they build their connectors,
they will keep them internal.
So you have to be using their
services to take advantage
of the first-class connector.
And the open-source
community, they've
done a great job of
responding to that,
and they started building
their own connectors.
But what we saw is that
created both a lot of friction
in the community as well as
confusion from customers about,
hey, what connection
should I really be using?
So at Google, we decided to
take a different approach.
All of the connectors
that we build from Hadoop
into the Google Cloud Platform,
those are fully open source.
So we chose to work with
the open-source community
instead of against them.
And our connectors,
they're also built
with these cross-team
collaborations at Google.
So our Google Cloud
Storage connector,
that is something
that we did hand
in hand with the
Cloud Storage team
to make sure that you're getting
the optimal performance out
of these connectors.
So to tell you more about
some of the new and improved
connectors that
are available, I'm
going to bring up Karthik,
who's actually one
of the engineers on that team.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: So
Dataproc is really the bridge--
like we see it as the bridge
between the Hadoop world
and Google Cloud.
So to kind of be clear
on what connectors means,
the idea is that you can
still store your data
in services like BigQuery
or Google Cloud Storage that
can be used through other
cloud platform tools
but, at the same time, process
your data through tools
that you're already familiar
with in your Hadoop ecosystem.
So the first--
I'm going to go through
a few new connectors.
And this is the
first one, I think
this is really the coolest.
It's a set of new
BigQuery read connectors.
So the old BigQuery
connectors, the way
it worked is it would export
data from BigQuery into GCS,
and then your job would
read the data from GCS.
What that meant is that
your cluster actually
sat idle for maybe
up to minutes as
that data was being exported.
Through this new
BigQuery storage API,
we can actually stream data
directly from BigQuery,
and BigQuery actually
intelligently dynamically
rebalances between map tasks
so that you don't end up
with [INAUDIBLE] and
the tasks actually
finish about the same time.
And we can also push down
predicate filters and column
filters into
BigQuery so that way,
you reduce the amount of data
that is actually read out.
And finally, the last
major improvement there,
as you look at Spark
in particular--
that's why I put it
up on the slide--
in the old connector, you'd have
to use the MapReduce API, which
is very difficult to work with.
But now we integrate with
the Spark data source API,
so now it's just
spark.read.bigquery,
give it a table name,
and you have a type data
frame that's correct that you
can use in your Spark jobs.
There's also a connector
for MapReduce as well.
So kind of similar,
there's another connector
as well for Cloud Spanner.
It is also open
source on GitHub.
Actually, all three that
I'm going to talk about
are on GitHub.
This one is still under
active development,
but kind of the
same concept here.
We push down filters, and it
integrates with the Spark data
source API, so it's just
spark.read.formatcloud-spanner,
and again, you have a correctly
typed data frame to work with.
And finally, I'll run through
some quick improvements
in the GCS connector.
There's been a lot
of work in the GCS
connector in the past year,
especially around performance.
So the first big one is
really around supporting
columnar file formats.
So the idea with these
columnar file formats,
you might have a footer
at the end of the file.
And so if you're
filtering data, you
might be able to
skip the entire file
or just read a
small section of it.
So we really improved
random access patterns
in the GCS connector, and
that's what really makes it up
to four times faster for
certain parquet workloads.
And the other major improvement
was around multi-threaded batch
requests.
So if you're renaming
a large directory
or deleting a large
directory, that
is now significantly faster.
And so, again, just
to kind of reiterate,
the big thing here
is we're really
focused on being good
open-source citizens.
Instead of proprietary
connectors,
these are all open
source on GitHub,
and the community can
also contribute to them.
And with that, I'll
hand it off to Mikayla
to talk about auto-awesomeness.
MIKAYLA KONST: All right.
So what is auto-awesomeness?
So auto-awesomeness
basically means
that we manage your
infrastructure for you
so that you can just
focus on the insights.
And we have a whole host of
different auto-awesome features
that help you do this.
So we have lots of features
that help you manage clusters.
So for example, one
is scheduled deletion.
So, let's say I have a
cluster and I want to say,
OK, if this cluster's idle
for more than 10 minutes,
I want Dataproc to just
automatically delete it
for you.
So you can set that up.
And then we manage
your jobs too.
So we have the Jobs API.
We have eight different
job types now,
so that it's easy to submit
jobs through whatever automation
that you're using.
And then we also have ways
to manage clusters and jobs
together.
So on the next slide,
I'm going to talk
about workflow templates.
So what is a workflow template?
What is a workflow?
So a workflow template is a
way to specify a graph of jobs
that you want to run, so any
arbitrary job dependencies,
alongside the configuration
for the cluster
that you want those
jobs to run on.
So when you run a
workflow, what happens
is Dataproc will spin up
a cluster on your behalf,
run the graph of
jobs on that cluster,
and then tear down the cluster.
And even if
something goes wrong,
the workflow will clean
up the cluster for you
so that you don't have
to worry about it.
You can do all of
this with a single API
call, which is really powerful.
So you can actually run a
workflow directly from the UI,
and then you can monitor the
progress of this workflow
as well.
So you can see the
jobs in this workflow.
This is just a simple teragen,
terasort, teravalidate.
The teragen job is done,
the terasort job is running,
and the teravalidate job is
waiting for the terasort job
to finish.
So another auto-awesome
feature that we
have for managing your
jobs, that's coming soon,
is the ability to see
all the logs associated
with a particular
job in Stackdriver,
logging all in one place.
So you can select
a particular job
by job ID in just a
dropdown, and then
you automatically see
all the driver logs
and all the container
logs all in one place here
in Stackdriver.
And Stackdriver is not
just used for logging.
It's also used for monitoring.
So we have full integration with
Stackdriver monitoring as well.
So we export metrics
from your cluster
to Stackdriver monitoring,
and that's actually
how our auto-scaler makes
decisions about how to scale.
So to talk to you more
about auto-scaling,
I'm going to hand it back
to Karthik real quick.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yes.
So I really see auto-scaling
as the premier auto-awesome
feature.
Because auto-scaling is kind
of really the story of cloud,
the idea that you just pay for
the resources that you use.
So with auto-scaling,
jobs are fire and forget,
and then auto-scaling can
scale up and down clusters
to match your workload.
So we still want to give
you low level control
into how auto-scaling works.
So importantly, you can
set the minimum cluster
size and the maximum
cluster size,
and you can also control how
aggressive the auto-scaler
responds to YARN metrics.
So just to kind of dig
in, Dataproc runs YARN.
It's called Yet Another
Resource Negotiator,
and it's kind of the
scheduler for Hadoop.
And all Hadoop jobs
run on top of YARN.
So if you take a MapReduce
job, for example,
a MapReduce job gets split
into a set of map tasks
and a set of reduce tasks, which
are then queued in YARN to be
scheduled on the cluster.
If there's a lot of work
pending in the queue,
then we should scale
the cluster up.
But if there's a lot of free
space left in the cluster,
then we should scale
it down because we
have too much capacity.
So we allow you to choose how
to respond to these YARN metrics
and how aggressively.
So for example, something
neat you can do,
is you can have very
high priority jobs,
you can actually set
it so the cluster just
scales up when you submit a lot
of jobs but only scales down
when the cluster's idle
to avoid interrupting
any jobs that are in progress.
So last year, we launched
auto-scaling to alpha.
This year, we're
launching it to beta,
and there have been a
whole slew of improvements.
And I'll go through a few here.
So first, we've enhanced
the fine grained controls
that you have over auto-scaling.
So for example, now you can
update auto-scaling policies
at any time, and you can also
stop auto-scaling in clusters.
This is especially important
for long-running clusters
where you might need to tune
the auto-scaler over time.
We've also focused
a lot on usability.
So you might have noticed
in the cluster page
that you now have a dashboard
of YARN in HDFS metrics.
And this really helps
understand why the auto-scaler
is scaling up or down
based on the utilization
in your cluster.
And we've also put the
auto-scaling decision history
in Stackdriver Logging as well.
And finally, we focused
on job stability--
the ability to scale up and
down MapReduce and Spark
jobs without having them fail.
And we'll touch on
that more a little
bit later, so I'm just
giving you a little teaser.
So let's switch gears here and
talk about preemptible VMs.
So preemptible VMs are kind
of a really neat concept
in Google Cloud.
They're instances that
are up to 80% cheaper
but can be preempted,
which really
means that they're
kind of taken away,
they're shut down
at any time if GCE
needs to sell that
capacity elsewhere.
So a lot of workloads are OK
with nodes joining and leaving,
and that means that these 80%
cheaper VMs can actually make
it way more cost effective.
So you think that
the Hadoop ecosystem
is built around this idea
of nodes coming and leaving,
so you add a bunch
of preemptible VMs
to your cluster.
But then, your jobs
start actually failing.
So Mikayla will talk a little
bit more about why this is.
MIKAYLA KONST: All right.
So you added a whole bunch of
preemptible VMs to your cluster
and your jobs started failing.
So what's going on?
So let's do a brief refresher on
the anatomy of a MapReduce job
to kind of understand
what's happening here.
So in MapReduce,
you got your mappers
and you got your reducers.
So you have your map tasks
running on those nodes,
and then your reduce
tasks need to fetch data
from your mappers.
So they fetch the output of
the map tasks from those nodes.
And so your job is going along.
It's almost done, but then one
of your mappers gets preempted.
And as a result of this,
all those reducers that
were fetching data
from that mapper,
those reduce tasks also fail.
So now, not only do you
have to rerun this map task,
you also have to rerun all those
reduce tasks that were fetching
data from that mapper.
So that's kind of unfortunate.
So we've actually
launched a feature
to alpha that helps
mitigate this issue.
So can you switch over
to the demo stream?
All right.
So this feature is called
Enhanced Flexibility Mode,
and we have it for both
MapReduce and Spark.
So Karthik, can you
start that video?
So first we're going to
show you an example of what
happens when you don't
have Enhanced Flexibility
Mode enabled.
So here, I am submitting
a job to a cluster,
and this is just a tiny
10-gigabyte shuffle.
And this cluster does not
have Enhanced Flexibility Mode
enabled.
So what we're going to do
is, once this job gets going,
I'm going to remove
the preemptible workers
from this cluster,
and we're going
to see what happens
to the job progress.
And it's not good.
So we're just waiting
for this to get started.
And then after
this, we'll show you
what happens when Enhanced
Flexibility Mode is enabled,
which is very exciting.
All right.
So we're going to switch
over to the Cluster tab here.
We're editing this cluster.
It used to have five
preemptible workers,
and we're reducing that to zero.
So now we're scaling
this cluster down,
getting rid of those instances,
and let's monitor our job
progress to see what happens.
I know that's kind
of hard to see
but it looks like we're at 71%.
We're chugging along.
If we go back over
to the Cluster tab
and look at those instances,
we see those VMs are now
getting removed.
All right.
So let's check back in on
the job, and all right.
It went down from 75% to 21%.
So all that progress was lost.
You have to rerun those tasks,
which is pretty unfortunate.
So Karthik, can you
switch to the next video?
So now we're going to
talk about what happens.
This is the exact same
setup but this cluster
has Enhanced Flexibility
Mode enabled.
So same set-up,
five preemptibles,
two normal workers
submitting the same job,
like a 10-gigabyte shuffle.
Yeah.
And then, so with
Enhanced Flexibility Mode,
we actually write the
output of those map
tasks to a distributed
file system
so that it's check-pointed and
you don't lose that progress.
So once a map task
has finished, it
will never have to be
rerun again for any reason.
So we'll watch the job
progress for this one
and see what happens.
So wait for the job to get going
and then scale down the cluster
again.
And now it's
important to point out
that in-flight map tasks
will still be killed,
so you will still see
some progress lost.
But all the map tasks
that are already done,
that progress is saved.
Right.
So we're switching over
to the Cluster tab.
We're going to edit the
configuration to only have
zero preemptible workers.
And then, again, we'll watch
what happens with that job.
All right.
So it looks like we're at--
I can barely read that--
58%?
We can go see those VMs.
Yeah.
All right.
The VMs are going away now.
So we can check
back in on our job.
All right.
So this time, the progress
went from 58% to 45%.
So that's like way less
dramatic than what it was before
in the other one, where it
went from like 75% to 21%
or something like that.
And then also,
keep in mind, this
is a tiny 10-gigabyte job here.
So for larger jobs,
the percentage
of the total job of progress
that is lost is a lot smaller.
Yeah.
So with this feature,
this is also--
it works well with scaling.
So I guess, if you wanted to
see no job progress lost at all,
you can actually use
Graceful Decommissioning.
So with Graceful
Decommissioning,
we wait for the containers
to finish on the nodes
before we remove the nodes.
And usually, so with
Enhanced Flexibility Mode,
this is a little bit different
than how YARN Graceful
Decommissioning normally works.
So with Enhanced
Flexibility Mode,
as soon as those containers
are done, so as soon
as those tasks are
done on those nodes,
we can remove the
nodes right away,
even if the application
isn't done yet.
So this is different
than how YARN Graceful
Decommission normally works.
Because normally,
those nodes have
to sit around for the entire
duration of the application
because they're still
serving shuffle data.
But now, they're not.
Now, that shuffle data is in
a distributed file system,
so we can remove those
nodes sooner and so now
scaling could be
more responsive.
And I'll hand it over
to Chris, I think.
We can switch back to
the questions slide.
Can we switch back to--
CHRIS CROSBIE: Do you
want to advance one slide?
MIKAYLA KONST: Can
you advance the slide?
Oh.
Oops.
OK.
I guess I can.
CHRIS CROSBIE: So yeah.
That's the end of the
session, everybody.
We did try to save
some time for Q&A
because there's probably
a lot of questions
about these features, and
we're happy to speak to those.
So anyone that wants
to come to the mic,
we're happy to answer questions.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
Did you have a chance to
benchmark the performance
impact of spilling all of
the shuffle data to disk
or, I mean, to, it
sounds like, GCS?
MIKAYLA KONST: Yes.
So we did some benchmarking.
So we benchmarked against
HDFS and GCS as well.
So for small to
midsize shuffles,
it actually looked all right.
For bigger shuffles,
that's something
that we're actually working
on actively this quarter
to improve it.
So this is kind of
like an alpha launch,
and we wanted to get
it out there for users
to start experimenting with.
So we're kind of
actively seeking feedback
for people who are
using this feature.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I have a question
about the auto-scaling.
Am I correct that this
auto-scaling is mostly
the horizontal,
it's not vertical?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Yes, that's correct.
It's only horizontal scaling.
AUDIENCE: Any plans?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: It's
something we've thought about.
But at the moment, no.
I mean, if you want to
talk about your use case,
I'd definitely be--
come and find me afterwards.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yeah.
I'm curious why you're
interested in it.
AUDIENCE: This
auto-scaler is vertical.
Do you basically have
your own-- like for Spark,
for example-- do you have
your own fork of Spark
to be able to do such a thing?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: So for
the Enhanced Flexibility part,
sort of yes.
And this is stuff that we
plan to open source, actually.
As we said earlier,
we are trying
to be good open-source
citizens here.
So Ben actually
is the person that
did Spark Enhanced Flexibility
and Mikayla did MapReduce.
AUDIENCE: And does
that rely on YARN?
I guess I--
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: So
Spark already schedules
its executives on YARN.
Spark on YARN is already
in the Spark project.
AUDIENCE: I'm thinking
in the future, that'll be
pretty awesome if we can run--
take advantage of this feature,
for example, in the Kubernetes
world and have the shuffle files
being stored in GCS, I guess,
is where I'm going with that.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Were you
saying-- sorry, in what world?
CHRIS CROSBIE: In Kubernetes.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Kubernetes, yes.
CHRIS CROSBIE: So, yeah,
because this is also a problem
that Kubernetes is trying
to resolve actively as well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
This is awesome.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yes.
Yeah.
Definitely all stuff
we're thinking about.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So my question is
more on, let's say
there's an optional
component that I installed
and you showed that you
have support for Flink 1.6.
But right now, Flink
is at 1.8, and there's
some features I want.
How easy is it to upgrade it?
Is there a way to
apply a patch or we
have to set up our own Flink
cluster across the cluster
ourselves, or is there a
way of easily upgrading it?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: So
if you're purely looking
for like a particular
patch, like a bug fix,
it's pretty easy.
Reach out to Dataproc
feedback, or I
can talk to you afterwards.
We do do patches.
If you're talking about
version upgrades of Flink,
that we do as well.
I mean, we do try to stay
pretty up to date, especially
in Spark.
But as people request newer
versions, we'll add them.
CHRIS CROSBIE: We do do our best
to keep up with the community,
and we really respond
as much as we can
to customers that are pushing
for the latest and greatest.
But you do have full control
of the virtual machines,
so if you wanted to upgrade
whatever is on the operating
system, you do have root access
to it and can do what you want.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And second question
is that Spark
has a lot of its
own optimizations,
such as adaptive execution mode
and cost-based optimization.
In your fork, are
you kind of letting
Spark do all its work that it
does or are you overtaking some
of the things that
Spark does to have
this enhanced flexibility or
check-pointing or those kinds
of things?
MIKAYLA KONST: Sorry.
Could you say it one more time?
Are we--
AUDIENCE: Like, do you override
Spark's native features
to have your own or are you
allowing Spark to do scheduling
in [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
All of that is the same.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
CHRIS CROSBIE: So it wasn't
clear through the presentation,
like enhanced flexibility right
now is purely around shuffle.
So like cached
data, for example,
is not yet enhanced-ly flexible.
AUDIENCE: My question
is more around,
like, let's say there's
skew in your data
and then Spark recognizes that
and dynamically repartitions
it.
So you're not
touching any of that?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
So, yeah, if you
turn on cost-based
optimization 2.3,
then yeah, then that
should all still work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
Thank you.
CHRIS CROSBIE: And then when
there are overlaps with this,
like, for instance, I
know Mikayla brought up
Graceful Decommissioning,
that is something
that we're trying to change
in the open-source Spark
and push upstream.
So when we do hit
the overlaps, we
are trying to work with
the community on it.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, I wanted to ask you
about Graceful Decommissioning.
Is it not fulfilling
the proposed
that you have presented already?
When you configure
Graceful Decommissioning,
is it not waiting until the
map job is done before--
MIKAYLA KONST: So, it does.
So right now, if you have
Enhanced Flexibility Mode
enabled, so we actually
made some changes
to Graceful Decommissioning
so that it works better
with Enhanced Flexibility Mode.
So it waits for
those map tasks to be
done before decommissioning
those nodes.
So what I was
showing in the demo,
I actually didn't use
Graceful Decommissioning,
and that's why we saw
some progress lost,
even with Enhanced
Flexibility Mode on,
because we didn't wait for those
in-flight containers to finish.
But with Graceful
Decommissioning,
we wait for the
containers to finish
but we don't wait for
the entire application
to finish because now we don't
need to because the shuffle
data is preserved.
The nodes don't
have to serve it.
Did that answer the question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I will have a look.
Thank you.
And I also wanted to say to
you that I have tried the HBase
initialization action.
It works really well.
MIKAYLA KONST: Oh good.
AUDIENCE: And I think that it's
also really well-documented.
I just wanted to say, I think
that maybe adding a dropdown
menu just below the
initialization action, where
you can quickly choose
the HBase, or Ranger,
or whatever you like,
might be a little more
appealing than having to
pull from cloud storage
and create a--
MIKAYLA KONST: Oh yeah.
I totally agree.
So there's--
AUDIENCE: --a suggestion.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
There's stuff in
the works for that.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yeah.
That's excellent feedback
and we are on it.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, guys.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
Hopefully by the next Next,
that will be there.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: First
question is, do you
have any plans to expand
the pre-built image list?
Right now, like if you
look at these options,
it's like comparing to a
general execution machine,
you have a long list of options.
But if you go Dataproc,
it's maybe like five,
six different options
off a pre-built image.
Do have any plan to support--
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yeah.
We tried to address this--
I think there's more
than five or six--
but we do try to address this
with custom images, where
you do have the
capability to come in,
put whatever you would
like on the image.
Oftentimes, enterprises with
strict security controls
will put their own
security constraints on it.
Or you might have some
additional version
that you want to
upgrade independently.
You have the ability to
do that, and then you
can create a custom
image and then
come back and use that image.
So we do give you
the flexibility
to do what you need
to do with the image.
AUDIENCE: So even without
any customization,
do you have any plan to support
CentOS and different kind
of operating system?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: So we just
added Ubuntu because we got--
AUDIENCE: I saw that.
Yes.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: --just
based on customer demand.
So if you do have
use cases for that,
I'd love to talk to you about
it and see if it makes sense
to do additional images because
that's where Ubuntu came from,
it was just customers
were asking for it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
CHRIS CROSBIE: As
well, a little bit more
background, Ubuntu is
also very straightforward
because it's the same packages
between [INAUDIBLE] and Ubuntu.
So that's another reason that
CentOS is potentially more
difficult to do.
AUDIENCE: We are looking
for CentOS support.
CHRIS CROSBIE: OK.
Cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The next
question is, what's
the difference between the
templates and Composer?
Is there any feature
function overlap?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
There's actually--
before I'll let them talk more.
But there actually is an
integration point between them,
so Cloud Composer does have a
workflow templates operator.
So you can drop into Composer
this operator, and that
will do all of your
Dataproc jobs and cluster
all as one black box
entity within Composer.
So there is an
integration point,
and that's how
customers typically
work together with them.
I don't if you want
to add more to that.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
I mean, I was basically just
going to say the same thing.
Like, a Dataproc workflow can
be like one node in a Composer,
like a bigger Composer
orchestration.
So Composer is
integrated with all sorts
of different things in GCP.
Workflow templates are kind of
our Dataproc-native workflows.
So you could do the
same thing in Composer,
but it's kind of
annoying in Composer
to have to be like, OK,
let me create a cluster,
and then submit these jobs,
and then tear down the cluster,
like all these nodes in the
graph, where, logically, it's
just one operation.
So Dataproc does this part
of my overall pipeline.
AUDIENCE: So then,
another two question then.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yes, sure.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any-- like, say,
I don't want to have two
different templates over there.
One is built on
top of the Airflow,
the other is built on
top of the templates.
Is there any way I can use the
same templates in Composer?
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
So there's a workflow operator,
like a Dataproc workflow
operator, in Airflow.
So you can use your
same workflow templates
from Dataproc in Composer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: And one
of the things to consider
is that Dataproc
workflow is really
just a convenient
way of saying, I
want to run these
jobs in this cluster.
But there's no actual
native scheduling.
If you want to say, run
this job twice a day,
or when data arrives in GCS--
AUDIENCE: But still,
you have some overlap
to function between templates
and the Composer, right?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's
only if these two are
totally exchangeable
and compatible,
I might take their approach.
Otherwise, I will stay
with Composer, right?
CHRIS CROSBIE: It
just comes down
to our general theory about, we
try to expose a lot of knobs.
And so you want to turn
the more detailed knobs,
you can do that
directly in Composer.
You want to abstract
that all away
and treat it as one workflow
template box, you can do that.
And that way, you
might even have,
depending on what
organization you're in,
there might be somebody that
does the Dataproc workflow
templates, and then it can
hand off that entire black box
to the person doing Cloud
Composer or Airflow workflow.
So it's just sort of, where do
you want to turn those knobs?
AUDIENCE: I definitely see the
value of the templates here,
but I just don't want to
have two different versions
of templates-- one in
Dataproc kind of templates
and the Composer--
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Sure.
And feel free to
come talk to us later
about your use case as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
For the Spark
BigQuery connector,
you guys removed the
intermediate storage when
you're reading, but did you also
remove that for writing as well
or just writing
is still writes--
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN:
So right now, this
is just the read connector.
So there's not a similar
write connector yet.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like the
other thing is like the write
character is whenever--
it's a two-step process, right?
So yes, you're writing
to GCS, and then
GCS loads into BigQuery, but
sometimes the load fails.
But your connector
doesn't retry [INAUDIBLE],,
like we'll have to see.
Is there a way for you to retry?
Because it's part of
your connector, right?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Yeah.
A lot of the libraries
have low-level retries.
But, yeah, that's
something to look into.
Again, our connector
is on GitHub,
so if you found issue there,
we'll also take a look.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So this is more of
a follow-up question
on Graceful Decommissioning
and the flexible scheduling.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: So if
Graceful Decommissioning
will wait until the completion
of the task regardless, right,
so in the original version, when
you saw that 50% drop, if you
had Graceful
Decommissioning, would you
have seen any drop at all?
MIKAYLA KONST: So we wouldn't
have, but it's kind of a pain
because the nodes wouldn't
be removed from the cluster
until the application
is completely done.
So I guess another big benefit
of the Enhanced Flexibility
Mode is you can remove
nodes from your cluster
faster so you're not paying
for them when all you're doing
is serving shuffle data.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Is there like--
MIKAYLA KONST: And it's also--
AUDIENCE: --a breakdown on--
sorry.
MIKAYLA KONST: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was
considering like, if that's
the main benefit, this
new feature in the sense
that you can tear
down faster, do
you have any kind of numbers
on what the distribution, what
the benefit is of a job to its
shuffle time and to the cost?
MIKAYLA KONST: So I don't have
exact numbers on me right now.
AUDIENCE: Well,
just a general idea.
MIKAYLA KONST: So,
I guess, again,
for small or medium-sized
shuffles, the times of the jobs
are comparable, I guess.
And then for larger
shuffles, sometimes--
especially if you're
using HDFS, there
can be some bottle-necking
issues with the NameNode.
And you can tune the
NameNode to avoid those.
If you've use GCS, you don't
see those issues as much.
But, yeah.
CHRIS CROSBIE:
Essentially, this is
why we decided to make
this feature a public alpha
versus a EAP or a private
alpha because we want
as many people
testing it as possible
so we can start to
do these benchmarks
and figure out best practices.
And that way, when we do
hit EA, which is, hey,
we really trust this, that's
going to become coupled with,
and here is the type of
cost savings you can expect
or here is the kind of
trade-offs you can expect
with these different settings.
And so we do plan to get more
crisp on a lot of that stuff.
But right now, it's just
about getting it out there,
getting folks using it,
and starting to test out
a lot of this stuff.
MIKAYLA KONST: And
then again, one
of the huge reasons
we did this feature
is to help you
with cost savings.
So I guess, if you want to
use a lot of preemptible VMs--
so I guess, in the
demo, I showed me
purposely removing
the preemptible VMs,
but you don't know when
the preemptible VMs are
going to go away.
So when the preemptible
VMs get preempted,
there's no Graceful
Decommissioning there, I guess.
So I guess that's why
I demoed what I did.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so if a
preemptible gets preempted,
it still doesn't
gracefully decommission?
MIKAYLA KONST: It does not.
No.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
So it's to help with that.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I one
quick one afterwards.
MIKAYLA KONST: Yeah.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Basically,
for the auto-scaling,
I noticed it's in beta.
Do you guys have an
idea or a timeline
for when it would be in GA?
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: Not a
firm timeline, but the idea
is in the next quarter two.
CHRIS CROSBIE: Yeah.
Very soon.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool Thank you.
CHRIS CROSBIE: Yep.
KARTHIK PALANIAPPAN: All right.
Well, thanks for coming.
CHRIS CROSBIE: Thanks
for sticking around.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]